When performing an analysis, we can usually achieve statistical rigor by
way of a significance test. These test to find whether or
not a sample of data can disprove some conventional wisdom or
assumption, with a predefined level of confidence. Let's first discuss at
a high level why statistical rigors important. Let's say that you
worked in an office of 1000 people, and you wanted to
find out what the most popular favorite color in your office
was. It would be a lot of work to ask all
1,000 people. So you decide to just poll 10 people
to get a pretty good idea of the office's favorite
color. When you ask these 10 people, each one says
"blue." With that statistic, you might say," Well, since these
10 people out of 1,000 said blue is their favorite
color, blue must be everyone in the office's favorite color."
Of course both you and I have some intuitive idea
that this probably isn't true. We just happened to come
across ten people who all liked blue. Statistics formalizes
this kind of logic. So we can assess the feasibility
of a result that we get with a smaller
sample when trying to say something about a larger population.